[Musique]
s est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
nicolas mathieu bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau prix goncourt
en 2018 pour leurs enfants après eux
connemara qui est sorti il ya quelques
semaines est votre troisième roman chez
actes sud un succès en librairie ce
titre connemara nicolas mathieu c'est
celui de l'un des plus gros succès de la
chanson française
voilà la terre
[Musique]
l'hiver
on y lit on
autant d'égards
sarr de décembre 1981 vous nicolas
mathieu que d'aucuns présentent comme
celui comme l'écrivain de la france
périphérique marqué à gauche si vous
avez choisi ce tube d'un chanteur de
droite ça n'est pas que pour la blague
moi je n'ai pas choisi en tout cas en
pensant aux couleurs politiques de
michel sardou c'est ce titre i dit autre
chose du contenu du livre ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette chanson c'est
qu'on la connaît tous ce qu elle aime
qu'on la déteste qu'elle nous est
commune et en même temps que s'ils
signalent une ligne de démarcation entre
nous parce que vous savez c'est là c'est
cette chanson qui clôt toutes les
soirées de la chaussée et des écoles de
commerce en général et en même temps
c'est une chanson qu'on écoute dans les
bals populaires dans les mariages et
selon qu'on les écoute hec ou dans un
bal populaire c'est pas la même manière
d'écouter ça dit pas la même chose et ce
roman et raconte un peu ça aussi ce
qu'est ce qui se trame dans dans la
france ce qui ce qui nous est commun les
possibilités de rencontrer aussi les les
frontières qui demeurent entre nous
autour de l'axé pour les vivants chante
sardou dans votre connemara ensuit
l'année christophe deux anciens
camarades de lycée qui vivent à la
quarantaine venue une histoire d'amour
tardive et adultère c'est d'être vivant
précisément dont il est question ouais
il ya ça aurait effectivement c'est à
dire que tous les deux ils se réveillent
à la quarantaine au milieu de leur vie
comme ça ils se demandent
s'ils ont pas emprunter les vite
quelqu'un d'autre et ils ont envie de
voilà deux de réprouver d intensité qui
l'aurait et chrysler sont devenus
étrangères et rejoue une partie de leur
jeunesse pour quoi faire voilà le
bouquin traite de ça et puis en mettant
les lacs du connemara en couverture il y
avait l'idée aussi de dire que ce roman
s'il a un caractère un peu épique comme
cette chanson mais une épopée des
classes moyennes voilà
connemara encore une fois même si on
déteste cette chanson ça pousse quand
même et même les gens qui la déteste et
je reçois beaucoup de messages à ce
sujet là me disent qu effectivement en
fin de soirée ça produise ses effets
être vivant est ce qu'on en fait
effectivement est ce que ça nous fait on
dit de ce livre qu'il est traversé par
la question qu'est ce que c'est au fond
réussir sa vie pourquoi ne pourrait-on
pas nicolas mathieu résister précisément
à l'injonction de répondre à cette
question
parce que la jonction n est pas dans la
question elle est dans les solutions
proposées c'est à dire qu'il ya une
sorte de cahier des charges clair
d'ailleurs qui varie selon les époques
selon les moments mais la société nous
vend des images de réussite elle nous
vendaient des bonnets des parcours de
rêve des cursus honorum de la réussite
bien sûr alors en tout cas
réussir sa vie ce serait effectué sa
puissance réaliser ce qu'on a on nous
met pas forcément en respectant le
dessin qui nous est assignée par
d'autres mais la question d'avoir une
vie qui vaut le coup elle se pose à
chacun et ça c'est pas une assignation
elle se pose ne serait ce que pour une
queue pour une raison c'est que notre
vie est elle n'est pas éternelle elle
est finie dans le temps et que du coup
la consommation de ce temps là qu'est ce
qu'on va en faire c'est une question
brûlante pour chacun et qui devient de
plus en plus brûlante à mesure que le
temps passe ce livre est il une réaction
à la façon dont le précédent a été
accueillie c'est à dire fort bien par le
prix goncourt mais aussi je crois
comprendre par une forme de méprise dans
ce qui a pu être vos intentions vous
dites que vous pensiez vous dépeindre de
grands vivent dans leurs enfants après
eux on y revient cette façon d'être
vivant et en l'occurrence on vous a
félicités pour avoir extrêmement bien
décrit des loosers exactement c'est
alors pas tout le temps partout pas tout
le monde mais j'ai une longue longue
tournée après le prix goncourt est
souvent me disais mon dieu ils sont
attachants mais sont des vies de merde
et ça me plaît beaucoup moi je n'avais
jamais conçu comme ça j'ai trouvé au
contraire qu'il avait des vies puissante
effectivement et que réussir sa vie ou
avoir une existence valable ça dépendait
pas de sa promotion sociale ça ne
dépendait pas de sa puissance économique
qui jouaient des choses peut-être à
plus basse intensité mais qui avait
autant de valeur et que c'est peut-être
un des des amorces de ce deuxième roman
de se dire voilà hélène elle a tout
réussi en théorie et en même temps elle
est travaillée par des les affects
sombre à 40 ans elle se dit mme mais
est-ce que j'habite pas la vie de
quelqu'un d'autre est-ce que c'est lié
au fait que votre position avoue nicolas
mathieu elle est comme vous le dites
intercalaire de ceux qui ont eu honte de
leurs origines et plus tard qu'ils ont
eu honte d'avoir eu honte un genre de
transfuges à votre corps défendant ou
qui seraient peut-être pas tout à fait
déconstruit c'est un mot à la mode ça en
tout cas je me trouve effectivement dans
une position intermédiaire entre deux
mondes celui que j'ai quitté celui où
jeu dont je ne serai jamais tout à fait
parce que je n'y suis pas née voilà
entre les classes moyennes et puis la
bourgeoisie culturel on va dire est que
ce lieu là que j'habite malgré moi est
définitivement il me fait me poser des
questions sur les valeurs de chacun
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'ils
considéraient comme une vie réussie en
bas en haut à droite à gauche et c est
que ça privilégie un netto je dirais de
voyeurs c'était une manière d'être au
monde où on est très peu d'acteurs et on
considère les raisons de chacun c'est
pas très confortable mais ça se prête
bien à la littérature cette ligne de
fracture qui est la vôtre et celle de la
france que vous décrivez la france qui
avance versus la france qui stagne
celles qui restent celles qui par celle
qui est efficace dans qui revient
beaucoup contre celle qui ne l'est pas
celle qui a les codes celles qui ne l'a
pas est ce que cette ligne de fracture
ce qu'elle se creuse mais déjà il
faudrait interroger les mots que vous
employez qui sont d'ailleurs su que tout
le monde emploie 1 je sais je vous en
fais pas le leur reproche mais celle qui
avance et celle qui stagne non il y en a
une qui avance dans le sens du courant
et une autre peut-être qui lui résiste à
ce ne sont pas les miens j'ai commencé
par là en disant que je vous en faisait
pas leurs proches du tout c'est comme au
moment de l'élection de 2017 on
utilisait la france de l'ouverture l
affront du repli non et des gens qui ont
les moyens de gagner dans le monde tel
qu'il va et puis à d'autres qui sont que
qui sont très exposés à des violences
sociales économiques diverses quoi dans
le monde tel qu'il est et c'est ça qui
est les questions qui se pose est est-ce
que cette fracture s'accroît je pense
oui oui on est dans un moment où la
richesse quand même va un peu toujours
haut dans le même sens et qu'elle a
produit n'est les fractures plus
profondes voilà qu'est quid de la classe
moyenne et un jour ou l'autre quel
visage aura notre démocratie dans un
monde où justement ce
cette population du milieu en fait tant
à s'étirer de plus en plus et qu'est ce
qui alimente
le creusement de la fracture qu'est-ce
qui ronge les choses est ce que c'est
une forme de mépris mais qu'il irait
peut-être dans les deux sens il ya mille
choses déjà il ya la structure
économique qui qui ait du monde dans
lequel on vit qui fait que le la
l'argent serait partie pas de manière
égalitaire du tout très au contraire
mais dans les années 30 c'était déjà
comme ça allait tous les arbitrages ont
été faits après la deuxième guerre
mondiale ont consisté à rééquilibrer ces
choses là et puis oui il ya des affects
les gens qui se sentent méprisés
d'autres qui les regardent de haut des
gens qui disent qu'ils qui pense
vraiment que leurs intérêts sont
toujours les bons et que finalement si
d'autres noms ont nourrissent de
différent ce qu'ils n'ont pas bien
compris ils sont passés intelligent
peut-être qu'on a manqué de pédagogie à
leur endroit donc voilà tout ça
effectivement ça nourrit à la fois des
inégalités mais aussi beaucoup de
ressentiment vous avez dit récemment
vous avez mis face à face la gauche
hypokhâgne et la gauche bac pro est-ce
que d'une certaine façon il n'ya pas
l'expression je voudrais pas vous
contrarier mais d'une forme de
condescendance en disant ça en disant
qu'il faudrait que la gauche dont vous
vous revendiquez
s'exprime ou en tout cas se saisissent
différemment des choses en fonction
quelles séquelles et hypokhâgne ou quel
bac pro alors oui je pense pas être
condescendant du tout
une chose très simple j'ai dit si bien
qu'il y ait une gauche hypokhâgne et
voilà urbaine polyglotte ouverte sur le
monde voilà qui tire son épingle du jeu
ça me va très bien mais là la gauche
elle a une vocation historique est quand
même de représenter les modes de vie
dominée et notamment les classes
populaires vers les gens qui font pas
des études très longues qui mènent des
vies peut être économiquement plus
difficile et c est que c'est quand même
un chant qu'elle en grande partie
abandonné on a eu souvent l'impression
que le peuple n'était pas à la hauteur
de la gauche il me semble que le sel
inverse qui devrait se poser comme
question comment la gauche peut se
saisir des intérêts des classes
populaires ça fait partie de son adn et
de sa mission historique on est à moins
de trois semaines d'une élection
présidentielle une campagne drôle de
campagne que celle de cette année le
contexte international en a parlé à
l'instant étant ce qu'il est comment est
ce que vous pensez que la la colère
sociale qui s'est exprimée ces dernières
années qui ne date pas du mandat d'
emmanuel macron mais qui sait peut-être
exprimé différemment va se manifester
c'est drôle parce que j'y réfléchissais
là je me disais ça me faisait penser à
la pièce de giraudoux là la guerre de
troie n'aura pas lieu l'impression que
l'élection présidentielle n'aura pas
lieu c'est en fait
vu le contexte international
on sait à l'ailé les dés sont jetés un
petit peu déjà quand même et que ça va
produire ça certainement dû pas mal de
des pieds de refouler c'est à dire que
finalement le dans une démocratie les
élections c'est le lieu où se métabolise
les intérêts contradictoires et et où
justement ses colères ces violences
peuvent prendre une forme pacifiée dans
le temps de débat et là j'ai
l'impression que sa nouvelle ce
travail-là de métabolisation ne se fera
pas et que ça trouvera d'autres voient
sans doute par la suite que c'est pas
une forcément une bonne nouvelle c'est
quoi d'autre on voit ben je ne sais pas
je suis pas un devin mais voilà je pense
par exemple que les gilet jaune c'était
que clairement un sursaut une convulsion
du corps social qui est parce que les
des intérêts des idées des affects et ne
trouve pas à s'incarner autrement dans
le champ politique traditionnelle vous
fait faire une interview très politicien
effectivement pas question dans cette
campagne et quelques ailes quelle
tournure ça apprendra bien heureux ou
malheureux celui qui pourra le dire on a
on avait d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
choses dans ce livre on n'a pas le temps
de parler tout il est aussi beaucoup
question d'amour bien sûr nicolas
mathieu connemara dont chez actes sud
merci beaucoup d'être rire sur nous en
dire quelques mots et puis de tout ce
qui va autour